most of us are familiar with the equal
sign from our earliest days of
arithmetic you might see something like
1 plus 1 is equal to 2. now a lot of
people might think when they see
something like this that somehow equal
means give me the answer 1 plus 1 is a
problem equal means give me the answer
and 1 plus 1 is 2. that's not what equal
actually means equal is actually just
trying to compare two quantities when i
write 1 plus 1 equals 2 that literally
means that what i have on the left hand
side of the equal sign
is the exact same quantity as what i
have on the right hand side of the equal
sign i could have just as easily have
written 2 is equal to
1 plus 1. these two things are equal i
could have written 2 is equal to 2. this
is a completely true statement these two
things are equal i could have written
one plus one
is equal to one plus one i could have
written one plus one minus one is equal
to
is equal to
three
minus two
these are both equal quantities what i
have here on the left hand side
this is
this is one one plus one minus one is
one and this right over here is one
these are both equal quantities
now i will introduce you to other ways
of comparing numbers these are the equal
signs when i have the exact same
quantity on both sides now we'll think
about what we can do when we have
different quantities on both sides so
let's say i have the number
three
and i have the number one and i want to
compare them
so clearly three and one are not equal
in fact i can make that statement with a
not equal sign so i could say 3 does not
equal 1. but let's say i want to figure
out which one is larger and which one is
smaller so if i want to have some symbol
where i can compare them where i can
tell where i can i can state which of
these is larger
and the symbol for doing that is the
greater than symbol the greater than
symbol this literally would be read as
three
is greater than
one three is a larger quantity and if
you need if you have trouble remembering
what this this means greater than the
larger quantity the larger quantities on
the opening the larger on the the larger
i guess if you could view this as some
type of an arrow or i guess a well some
type of symbol that this is the bigger
side here you have this little teeny
tiny point and here you have the big
side so the larger quantities on the big
side this would literally be red as 3 is
greater than
so let me write that down greater
than
3 is greater than 1.
and once again it just doesn't have to
be numbers like this i could write an
expression i could write
i could write 1 plus 1 plus 1
is
greater than
is greater than
let's say
well just one one right over there this
is making a comparison but if what if we
had things the other way around what if
i wanted to make a comparison between
five
and
let's say 19.
so now the greater than symbol wouldn't
apply it's not true that 5 is greater
than 19. i could say that 5 is not equal
to 19. so i could still make i could
still make this statement but what if i
wanted to make a statement about which
one is larger and which one is smaller
well if in plain english i would want to
say 5 is less than 19. so i would want
to say let me write that down i want to
write 5
is less than
5 is
is less than
is
less
than
19. that's what i want to say and so we
just have to think of a mathematical
notation for writing is for writing is
less than
well if this is greater than it makes
complete sense that let's just swap it
around let's make once again the point
point towards the smaller quantity and
the big side of the symbol point to the
larger quantity
so here 5 is a smaller quantity so i'll
make the point point there and 19 is a
larger quantity so i'll make it open
like this and so this would be read as 5
is less than 19. 5 is a smaller quantity
than 19. i could also write this as i
could write 1 plus 1 is less than 1 plus
1 plus 1. it's just saying that this
statement this quantity one plus one is
less than
one plus one
plus one